et des bombardements qui indiquent l'ONU
à l'instant pour être avoir violé le
droit de la guerre les Russes sont
d'ailleurs laissé entendre hier que
d'autres épisodes à les suivre
conséquences aujourd'hui le pays est en
état d'alerte les sirènes ont retentit
tout à l'heure à Kiev mais aussi dans de
nombreux autres villes du pays on va
retrouver tout de suite à carquis notre
envoyé spécial Mélina Huet Mélina
bonjour les sirènes qui ont retenti
également à plusieurs reprises depuis ce
matin dans votre région à vous
tout à fait nous nous trouvons la
deuxième plus grande ville du pays
pourtant extrêmement habituée au
bombardement puisqu'elle a été
systématiquement pilonnée au début de
l'invasion pendant trois mois et
jusqu'en mai de nombreuses habitants ont
vécu dans dans le métro qui servait
d'abri anti-aériens alors depuis ce
matin de nombreuses alertes de vous le
voyez un petit peu peut-être derrière
moi il y a quand même des personnes qui
se déplacent tout simplement parce
qu'ici on a l'habitude il y a on a parlé
à
aux tenant d'un d'un petit café qui
était le seul à ouvrir hier qui a dit
non non moi contrairement aux autres
commerçants je ne vais pas descendre
dans la Brive parce que j'ai besoin de
faire du business d'ailleurs regardez
mon café il s'appelle bunker donc il y a
aucune raison qu'il soit visé il a dit
ça de manière ironique mais en réalité
les gens sont finalement accoutumés
assez assez frappe répétée nous sommes
descendus quand même dans le métro pour
voir qui était encore dans ce qui sert
aujourd'hui encore d'abris antiériens
alors que la situation dans le métro a
repris et il reste une quinzaine de
personnes nous allons parler à luriana
notamment qui nous a dit qu'elle restait
depuis le mois de mars dans ce métro
avec sa fille de 16 ans qu'elle n'en
sortirait pas tant que le ciel
ukrainien ne serait pas protégé et de
fait ce matin une vingtaine de missiles
ont été envoyées de longues portées
depuis la mer Caspienne mais également
depuis une ville russe proche du
Kazakhstan 20 missiles dont 5 ont été
abattus par les forces armées
ukrainiennes 12 ont touchés et d'autres
la région de ni pro faisant plusieurs
morts au moins un à Zapoli déjà et
d'autres morts admis pro et quant au
reste de ses missiles on ne sait
absolument pas quand et si ils vont
toucher l'Ukraine dans les prochaines
heures et c'est la raison pour laquelle
il y a toujours des alertes des sirènes
qui retentissent dans la ville et
d'ailleurs le maire de ralkif a en juin
la population à ne pas sortir de chez
elle et à aller dans les abris
entièresiens dès que les sirènes se
mettent en branle Mélina Huet en direct
de kerki merci à vous et également à qui
vous accompagne armée charrier bonjour
je me tourne vers vous on va décrypter
évidemment les enjeux de cette journée
il y en a un certain nombre puisqu'il y
a cette réunion par visioconférence des
membres du G7 autour de
vaux-le-limmerselinski il y a eu
beaucoup de noms beaucoup de réactions
hier à la suite de cette campagne de
bombardement on va parler aujourd'hui de
façon très concrète durant forcément du
soutien militaire oui qui va être
différent de ce qu'il était jusqu'à
présent c'est-à-dire que compte tenu des
bombardements qui a eu lieu hier qui ont
recommencé ce matin il faut lancer que
là avoir une défense qui soit une
défense entière il y en a comment est-ce
qu'on arrête les missiles comment est-ce
qu'on arrête les drones ce matin on fait
étape à peu près d'une quarantaine de
qui auraient été tirés et d'une
vingtaine de drones c'est difficile de
recouper les informations mais on voit
que les Russes sont en train de cibler
principalement tout ce qui est les
usines hydroélectriques qu'ils sont en
train de cibler les ne routiers qu'il
ciblent les villes pour montrer aussi
leur impact et que il cite aussi par
exemple de centre renseignement
ukrainien à Kiev qui sont touchés hier
donc il y a cette réalité derrière et
donc ça veut dire que du coup l'aide
ukraidiienne elle ne peut être à
condition qu'on fasse une sorte de
bouclier sur tous ces endroits là la
difficulté c'est qu'ils sont assez
espacés on l'a vu sur la carte quand
vous avez remontré c'est tout le
territoire ukrainien qui a été touché
qui est large si on part de l'Est et
qu'on va jusqu'à la ville de livres du
côté polonais et derrière ça demande
effectivement d'autres compétences que
les Occidentaux peuvent apporter alors
côté russe également on s'organise il y
a eu ce Conseil de sécurité hier matin
cette annonce aussi de rapprochement
avec misk la Biélorussie et puis demain
il y aura cette cette rencontre avec le
président turc Ratchet air tape erdoan
qui est donc vincentretenir
vraisemblablement avec Vladimir Poutine
la Turquie qui vient de s'exprimer il y
a quelques instants et qui appelle les
deux parties et les Russes et les Ukrain
à s'entendre à signer un cessez-le-feu
oui c'est la politique de erdoine depuis
le départ qui est de parler avec les
deux parties et d'amener en fait la fin
de ce conflit c'est ce qu'il souhaite
parce que la Turquie se veut être une
puissance régionale mais la guerre en ce
moment elle a lieu dans son espace
régional la Turquie elle est directement
concernée parce que il y a les trois des
Bosphore et d'artanel il y a on se
souvient quand il y avait des histoires
de céréales là aussi elles étaient
touchées donc elle a intérêt à calmer le
jeu donc le président
erdouane a un double chapeau de main en
quelque sorte quand il leur recevoir
Vladimir Poutine quand ils vont
s'entretenir si effectivement c'est le
cas c'est que il va être une puissance
régionale il va être le diplomate dont
vous avez parlé Élisabeth et dernier
point il est aussi un membre de l'OTAN
donc derrière il va pouvoir rapporter un
nombre d'informations aux Américains et
aux Occidentaux alors qu'est-ce qu'il va
en ressortir c'est là la difficulté
parce qu'on voit difficilement comment
est-ce que là on peut parler de cesser
le feu et comment est-ce vous trouvez un
accord mais il est en train de jouer
effectivement ce rôle prépondérant en ce
moment sachant qu'en plus c'est le
nouvel ordre qui se met en place puisque
il parle aussi avec les autres
puissances et des pays arabes qui sont
tout autour de cette de cette région là
merci beaucoup Armel pour le décryptage
voilà pour ces dernières réactions